para los que
creen que soy un inversionista
institucional con mucho dinero tuve que
poner una
una nota en mi twitter diciendo que yo
nada más sirviendo ensartan como una
manera de magnificar mi necesidad de
apoyar a los emprendedores pero sin
embargo para compensarlos les dije que
si querían yo podía y soy muy buena para
ello asesorarlos en su trabajo porque el
80% de las inversiones que nos llegan
ánsar tang son básicamente de que al
final te dicen neta no necesito tu
capital
quiero que me ayudes quiero que me
oriente es quiero que me pies quiero que
me centre y que me des
me abra los mercados pero tu capital no
necesito nos abrimos un cuestionario en
mi cuenta de twitter adonde les decía ok
dime cuál es tu cuento dime cuál es tu
problema y dicen los conocedores que en
los los estándares de solicitudes de
ideas y de inversión
el recibir 120 inquietudes
semanales es mucho señor recibo 120
inquietudes semanales en esa cuenta
diciendo oye este tengo este negocio oye
tengo este otro negocio
lo que más me impresiona es el las
preguntas estandarizadas y la cantidad
de ellas a donde dicen tengo 50 mil
pesos que hago con ellos para dónde voy
y si lo puedo entender en un país donde
no es excepción de la tendencia mundial
a donde la tasa de creación de empleo
corporativo es muchísimo menor que la
tasa de desplazamiento de empleo
corporativo por las de ni viento la
tecnología es un reto que estamos
teniendo en todo el mundo y méxico no es
decepción que de menos que gméxico de
todas maneras no ha sido el campeón de
la generación de empleos
es decir al principio de mis pláticas yo
siempre decía un emprendedor se hace no
un emprendedor nace y no es un rollo de
que tengo este dinerito con que emprendo
es un rollo de tengo la pasión interna
y la quiero desarrollar porque así soy
porque me lanzó al vacío y se ha
atrevido y tomó riesgos
eso es inicialmente ser un emprendedor
sin embargo recientemente con toda esta
mantenimiento como les digo de
desplazamiento del empleo y xavi la
posibilidad de nosotros generar empleo
en una economía de jóvenes como la somos
acepto la hipótesis de que el
emprendedor no nace sino que se tiene
que hacer o sea tenemos la obligación
patrimonial de crearnos un patrimonio y
de realizarlos como seres humanos y
parece ser que la puerta de hacerlo cada
vez más natural y cada vez más fuerte y
se acepta porque es un estudio de éxito
en todo el mundo es el emprendedurismo
entonces
ok no nace ese emprendedor no eres no te
atreves a gustarte al vacío no eres una
persona que
que hubiera preferido lanzarse con su
propio negocio pero no te queda de otra
entonces si es tu obligación social ser
un buen emprendedor y creerte la
y básicamente la plática de hoy la
quiero dedicar a todos ustedes en esa
parte o sea el cuarto no nos queda otra
que por la necesidad humana de
realizarnos como seres humanos a través
del trabajo
tenemos que crear tenemos que emprender
eso no nos exime de agarrar y decir
cuál es mi pasión no tengo 50 mil pesos
que hago con ellos básicamente la idea
es encontrar dentro de nuestras entrañas
cuál es nuestra pasión para hacer las
cosas eso es lo primero o sea es
básicamente agarrar y decir
que me apasiona hacer es encontrar
adentro de nosotros mismos qué es lo que
nos hace vibrar de manera individual y
diferencia a cada uno de nosotros
yo le he llamado muchas veces el hilo
conductor que nos rige que yo encontré
que constantemente me traía como imán a
todo aquello que significaba ayuda a la
gente y se vale decir bailar se vale
decir crear productos de x y y ceta pero
es algo que nos tiene que nacer adentro
y que tenemos que defenderlos como algo
tan diferenciado como nuestro dna
entonces esa es la primera obligación
que tenemos como jóvenes al salir al
mundo de decir qué voy a hacer con mi
vida útil profesional que va a regir
muchos de mis retos y muchas de las
cosas que quiero hacer de hoy en
adelante
el otro punto muy importante es ok me
apasiona
hacer
hablando de algo totalmente genérico
tutu
básicamente digo bueno ok me apasiona
hacer tu true la siguiente pregunta que
me tengo que hacer es el tutor tiene que
ser
algo con un objetivo social
[Música]
hace un par de meses llegó mi director
de publicidad y me dijo oye me acaban de
regalar 10 espectaculares cao con ellos
ayudamos en un plan de negocios y le
dije a ver cuál es su objeto social
cerrar con la cabeza y me dijo déjame
pensarlo y se fue a su lugar de origen y
regresa la semana y me dicen bueno nos
voy a crear tres empleos no es este
objeto social
todo producto así sea un producto un
table tiene que tener un efecto social
un table le hace bien a los señores oa
las señoras este cualquier cosa tiene
que tener un efecto social si no tiene
un efecto social si no le hace bien a la
sociedad olvídalo
no hay manera de que ese sea tu objeto
de desarrollo profesional como
emprendedor tienes que pensar que parte
de la sociedad le estoy haciendo bien y
piensa creativamente lo que les digo
hasta un table tiene un objeto social
ok
el ciclo que sigue entonces no es tengo
tanto dinero que hago con ese dinero es
básicamente agarrar y decir que le hace
bien a la sociedad
que le hace falta a la sociedad que yo
pueda aportar entonces así puedes hablar
de adentro de tu alma de dentro de tu
ser porque básicamente esas diciendo soy
un individuo que vino acá a hacer un
bien social
si no lo haces olvídalo no va a ser no
vas a emprender exitosamente
el tercer elemento
que tienen que tener básicamente es un
rollo de diferenciación
en los dices que yo les pido a mis
alumnos que hagan es cuál es su producto
qué bien le es a la sociedad
y cuál es su diferenciación
no importa que sea el spray que porque
creo que es más chiquito y se lo pueden
meter las señoras a la bolsa este eso lo
va a diferenciar del mercado y mejor si
es una diferenciación que sólo tú puedes
crear
por ejemplo yo tengo ahorita un producto
de vivienda social a donde pedir a unos
éste justamente emprendedores descartan
que son investigadores de la unam que
produjeran a mí
un material de construcción con una
fórmula que redujera significativamente
los costos del material no voy a
diferenciar y va a ser nada más mi
producto lo voy a patentar y nadie me lo
va a poder copiar entonces la
diferenciación mientras más propia la
puedas hacer
hazla porque eso es eso va a ser tú tu
prueba de fuego en tu aportación a la
sociedad
el siguiente punto importantísimo es
conoce tu mercado a qué mercado vas
tengo una chava espectacular de tartán
que produce fruta y utilizada
y es maravilloso lo que hace porque es
la única persona que ha encontrado que
la utilización mantiene la fruta en su
sabor original y scrunching es deliciosa
y límbert y se encontró que tenía
muchísimo problema con concentrar a su
producto al mercado y básicamente el
problema era que ya tenía competencia no
diferenciada
que varias empresas estaban importando
berries de chile rojas y a un precio
todavía menor por la diferenciación
también puede ser el precio
entonces de repente me dice cuál va a
ser mi diferenciación mi diferenciación
es que a los niños les encanta el snack
chiquito
soria estamos en la hipótesis con ella
de que su producto es básicamente un
producto para niños en envase más
chiquito y su fuerza interna no es
importar de chile wall mart para ponerle
sus stands su fuerza interna es ir con
las misses del colegio de decir mira
prueben un producto a los niños les
fascina y estamos empezando nuevamente a
tratar de diferenciar su producto de esa
manera a partir de su pasión que es la
utilización de la fruta mexicana
con esto quiero decirles que un producto
es una hipótesis
yo pienso que a la gente le va a servir
tal cosa
es una hipótesis no no te la juegues de
orgulloso de pensar que te conoces la
palabra que conoces la verdad porque
igual y mañana te quiero vender una
blusa de papel blanca porque a mí me
encanta y tú dices no gracias
estate listo a entender a tu público
como te dice no es por ahí yo tengo un
producto que son camionetas a gas
natural y dije es mi primer producto
especialización de impacto social
transformar el transporte público de
méxico
y en un año lo hago y el próximo año me
meto vivienda y el siguiente año me meto
otra cosa
y no fue así
mándela en mi camioneta tuvo éxito así
me di cuenta que lo que necesitaba era
que la conversión de gas natural fuera
diferente busca un proveedor regrese le
puse el lo que ellos querían no tuvo
éxito como yo hubiera querido porque me
di cuenta y es para que se den cuenta
que la cantidad de detalles de crear un
producto me di cuenta de que el gps que
yo estaba utilizando no era
suficientemente bueno y se robaban las
también estás constantemente en en
detrimento del cliente tuve que poner mi
propio gps para que no les robaban las
camionetas después me di cuenta que el
seguro tampoco era muy bueno tuve que
poner mi propia aseguradora para que
fuera rápido el seguro a cotizar
problemas de accidentes después me di
cuenta que las bancas no eran buenas
tuve que ponerle y ahora soy un líder
del mercado después de cinco años yo
creo que en un año yo voy a regresar la
vivienda luego el microcrédito y
especializando cinco años se llevó la
última parte que no deben de olvidar eso
es factor gobierno la última parte el
último
y tú ves que la secretaria de movilidad
no les daba placas por xz tuve que
hablar con otras de movilidad y decirle
cómo puedo ser tu aliado para que se
modernice el sistema de transporte
mexicano
para decirles no se desanimen sean
humildes crean un producto y pivote lo
pivote lo pivote lo hasta que finalmente
llegue a su maduración para escalar
exponencialmente sean humildes no que
quieran tener la razón nosotros hemos
tenido casos ensartan de gente dice es
que así se va a vender no se va a vender
muéstrame tus ventas tus ventas son tu
huella de tu éxito muestra de cuánto has
vendido
y en realidad no no ha metido nada el
siguiente punto importantísimo se
refiere básicamente
a que empieces chiquito
una persona llegó con nosotros el otro
día a entregarnos un producto que ya
tenía tras de sí diez mil francos
frascos de aerosol de limpieza de
higiene de genitales masculinos
y juraba el señor que era el producto
más más extraordinario y le había
invertido un millón de pesos
y con elegimos nova o sea no torno tiene
problemas de higiene masculina como la
que tú tienes la señora nos llama
curiosa su esposa nos llama y nos dice
es que le hicieron pensar tan que
invertir ese a mi pobre marido en mi
gente pues no le dijimos eso yo te
preguntará a uno de sus cuates o ayer tú
tienes problemas de esta naturaleza
oye prueba esto no en un frasquito
primero empieza probando entre tus
amigos si realmente su producto viable
empieza chiquito no te metas a problemas
de mayor de mayor envergadura
con esto te quiero decir que una vez que
tienes un producto probado el dinero es
un medio
no me decía el dinero abunda no es
cierto que hoy gana esto capital es como
hoy gana este trabajo no tú lo general
con tu preocupación y con la calidad de
la idea que puedas tener y te lo juro
que el dinero sea afuera y otro consigo
pero tráeme un buen producto
básicamente después me dices vamos ya
estoy lista ya tengo un año de ventas me
está yendo redondísimo ya tengo cartas
de aceptación de varios lados y necesito
capital porque capital mi capital
realmente te constriñe el capital te
pone a un capitalista encima de ti
tronando el dedo no y esos dos
emprendedores creen nada de mi dinero ya
me voy no es cierto el capitalista exige
vigilancia porque está invirtiendo su
capital no están no es el gobierno no
está regalando el dinero es porque no
pruebas deuda la deuda no te conseguir
tanto y si vas por capital que es el
otro gran problema que tenemos nosotros
por tanques estate listo aquí tienes un
socio acostúmbrate a tener un socio
adonde socio te va a decir me quedo
sentar en tu gobierno corporativo de que
hemos pedido un contador
te quiero pedir esto quiero pedir lo
otro y lo más importante de todo te
quiero pedir un plan de negocios y un
plan de negocios nada más
una hipótesis nuevamente el diseño de
una ruta que te dice vamos juntos así
que atreva menos a ser emprendedores
porque posiblemente no nos queda de otra
muchas gracias
gracias